the founder of a company that
distributes designs for untraceable 3d
guns is selling blueprints through his
website after a federal judge blocked
him from posting the instructions for
free on Monday the judge ordered Cody
Wilson and his company defense
distributed to remove the blueprints
from the Internet Wilson says he hasn't
violated that ruling is now charging
customers who can name their own price
for those designs 2013 Wilson became the
first person to fire a bullet
successfully from a home printed 3d gun
and Cody Wilson is with us from Austin
Texas good morning
Cody let me ask you this cost is fight
this fight has cost you a whole lot of
money and will probably cost you more in
legal fees why are you so committed to
making sure people can gain access to
these files well I think it's a matter
of principle I know it's absurd to some
degree to fight for your principles in a
culture like this but I think it's a
worthy demonstration and of course I
could always demonstrate like today that
I could always sell these files and I'll
continue to do so what is the principle
at the center of this though that you're
fighting for oh well like state
governments have no power to
second-guess the decision making of the
State Department they have no power to
ask websites to take information off of
the internet and it's legally posted
there I'm certainly not going to consent
to the judgments of judges that say that
they can Cody how many of these
blueprints have you sold oh gosh many
hundreds more probably than thousands at
this point the news was you know well
received mm-hmm and are you tracking who
you're selling these blueprints to oh
sure sure I'm required to do all kinds
of screening and stuff you know I can
only ship the US person's US citizens
there's all kinds of arms export control
stuff that we have to comply with but of
course I've had many years to become
comfortable and become compliant with
these laws I mean these blueprints allow
you to make an ar-15 the ar-15 is
illegal in seven states
will you sell blueprints of that type in
the states where it is against the law
the air 15 is in different
configurations legal to make in every
state in this country even today so no I
there's there's no difference
or there's no need really to separate
the kind of file that you can get or
somehow distinguish between the pure
information that you can receive so even
if I couldn't make an air 15 in
California which I can I can still have
the file for an air 15 this is a
separate question of law at a separate
question of fact Kody recently there was
a shooting at a Madden game tournament
by somebody who had a history of mental
health issues
I presume ibly they could get your file
and and use it does that concern you
sure I mean there's always the
possibility that people with a history
of mental illness can get access to
information and somehow do something bad
with it but we live in a nation of laws
and you should prosecute crimes after
the fact you know this this gentleman
who shot up this game tournament in
Florida legally bought that firearm the
law is there to prevent bad things from
happening but but did you know more than
that but Kody after the fact here is a
situation where people are already dead
sorry there's a First Amendment and
there's a Second Amendment Congress
shall make no law and the rights should
not be infringed it's pretty easy text
it's not very complicated
are you in favor Kody of gun control in
any form I suppose it depends on what we
mean right like in a community of law
makers get together and can the public
vote on things of course I understand
that we have institutions we have laws
but you will have to follow those just
like I follow the order of a judge and
in Seattle yesterday but the Second
Amendment Cody even according to judge
Scalia is not absolute and there can be
limits on it so it doesn't mean that you
can just have any kind of firearm of any
sort well I don't know I tire of this
decision-making or like this this style
of interpretation of laws like simply
because there can be limits on Rights
isn't somehow like an invitation to
censorship or to restriction of these
rights this is not an American attitude
and I find it frankly like the attitude
contain their somewhat suspicious but
the American attitude is based on a
judge in the Supreme Court that's a part
of the American system interpreting by
the way judge Scalia was not exactly
soft on the original intent of the
Constitution so if he thought there
could be some limits on the Second
Amendment surely he's worth listening to
just because there can be limits there
should be I mean this is the implied
nature of your question that the
American attitude to law is that law is
there to secure the liberties the
blessings liberties for the people not
to somehow justify restrictions and
regimes of control for petty state
governments like the Pennsylvania
Attorney General this is absurd but part
of the concern that they have about the
3d printing is that it you can't trace
it back to where that where it can't be
traced back there's a case in Utah where
a guy said listen I wanted to print this
gun because I could use it in his case
he said form a school shooting and it
would not be it would be very difficult
to trace it back to me does that concern
or bother you I think this guy was
promptly dealt with right I mean when
you make when you make a credible threat
of violence you can be charged under the
law and dealt with I mean as far as I
understand the system worked
just because someone expresses criminal
intent that somehow it doesn't mean that
like the public would like can't have
access to information or like somehow
can't go to a public library and learn
how to make a gun anymore I didn't
invent that you know what I mean well of
course in his case he would say he was
just expressing his First Amendment
rights to speech and then you're
suggesting that those rights should be
limited by by the law but that's that's
all the time we have Cody thanks so much
for being with us my pleasure